what is the
what do you charge per month on the only
fans to watch the show uh while i'm
filming it's 50 but like in between time
it's probably like 25 30. so 50 a month
to watch the show like as it's going on
uh-huh
only fans gets their cut i don't even
know what it is what is it 30 no they
just take off their percent so if it's
50 they'll take off 10 off each cell and
you get 40.
how many subscribers at one time have
you had like the peak
probably like 2 000 damn that's good
money times 50 150 yeah exactly
yeah
like but but it comes in every month
though yes residual income yeah so you
know because even if someone subscribed
they their intent might be to describe
subscribe for one month they don't
forget to cancel exactly and it's only
50 25 50 a month
damn have you thought about [ __ ] on
only fence
you know tiger be on there with his dick
out bro
that's why i did the blue girls club i
wanted to get only fans but i didn't
want to show my dick yeah
once you show your dick you can't go
back from that yeah it's kind of like
yeah kind of just a porn star at that
point